it has been actually wonderful to come
back to New Haven and to Yale it's a big
pleasure to see that the building is
still here and still one recognizes not
only the building but some of the faces
there was a nice experience to get back
thanks for inviting me today we'll talk
to you a little bit about heat waves in
a changing climate and I think the
subject heat wave is warm that will
become more and more important if
climate change proceeds as we believed
and one reason is is really that our
climate will experience some warming and
so whether this warming affect summer or
winter will be make a big difference for
instance in winter you see here how you
could define the climate as the
distribution of annual seasonal mean
temperature and now if there is some
shift in climate as we anticipate that
this would happen it would look
something like that and you see that
actually every second year from the
future climate which still classified
kind of the cold wintery some middle two
years would classify as warm winter
years today so nothing completely new
and actually the other half this will
overlap with all the seasons so winter
season in the extra tropics is nothing
completely new you know after climate
change but in summer it situation looks
kind of different actually if we think
of a warming which maybe is a little
larger in some of four and a half
degrees then we yield an essentially new
climate so this the distribution of
years that we will see in the future
might well be completely different so
the summer will deliver an unexperienced
climate to us now I will and of course
this will be associated also with a
number of heat waves I will be showing
you some examples I will first look a
little back and look into a couple of
historical heat waves that had made some
influence and how we think about heat
waves today I will present you a little
bit about what I call the variability
hypothesis I will show you a little
information on recent scenarios so
recent modeling results and
they are anticipated scenarios for heat
waves and then we will look into two
specific aspects of heat waves that play
an important role in how these features
develop now to begin with the first
example is the North American drought
1988 and this is an interesting story
because this diagram to the left shows
you the precipitation anomaly from April
to June and you see that there was a
this was down to 10% of the normal
precipitation in a large area of North
America and only a few months back in
December there was a paper published by
Kevin Trenberth in science and his paper
had the title origins of the 1988 North
American route so the same year the
issue was resolved and actually nobody
questions their conclusion of that paper
so it was immediately accepted that this
drought had been caused by large-scale
quasi-stationary Rossby wave patterns
you see this year
these waves pétanque stretching or
starting in the Central Pacific in
response to anomalous sea surface
temperatures in the tropical Pacific so
it was a strong La Nina event and this
start this North American drought also
brought the number of studies on the
role of land surface processes in a
drought and some of that actually has
been done also at Yale at that time now
another big heat wave that came up seven
years later in North America was the
Chicago heat wave and the unusual thing
about the Chicago heat wave was the
extremely high temperature that occurred
were observed during daytime at 8:00
during night times and so what you see
here are apparent temperature so
combining the influence of heat and
moisture stress and you see that over
this period considered here the mean
temperature that mean max temperature
was 48 degree centigrade the apparent
temperature and even the minimum
temperature is the nighttime temperature
in the middle was 27 degrees up to 30
degrees so these are extremely high
nighttime temperature
temperature and they were later being
identified as being the main cause
behind one of the results of this
heatwave name this was a large number of
heat death so they were I think about
800 victims of that heat wave in Chicago
in the town of Chicago alone and this
heat wave was the first probably when
that was realized on a grand proportion
and there was then a later paper
published in a bulletin where with the
title impacts and responses to the 1995
heatwave a call to action and his paper
you something is pointed out that still
today we are not really aware of namely
that in the annual average probably heat
waves is diversity metrological event
available in terms of casualty it's you
see here the numbers for the United
States tornadoes heavy floods maybe 100
200 casualties but east-west estimated
number 1000 and the maximum event it
goes down to here 10,000 casualties
estimated for 1980 and similar amount
for the heatwave in 1901
so that heatwave actually is a is really
important for us and a few years later
so maybe I should say how this was
perceived in Europe so first in Europe
they there were some heat rays but
nothing was in the category where we
would be concerned about health effect
and so when the European heat wave 2003
came up you see here some pictures a
river close to where I live and here the
temperature anomaly of that heat wave
this heat wave did hit really an ant an
unprecedented heat wave did struck an
unprepared Society and I can show you
this pose for more first for the impacts
of the teet wave which were quite
dramatic so you see here some data from
France so you see the excess mortality
which is the mortality above the
long-term mean as a function of time
starting from August 1 to November 30
and you see the first two weeks which
were the first two ratios the strongest
heat waves in this particular case and
you see how the
mortality rate exceeds the long-term
average by 150 percent on the national
average so that means that if you go to
the hot spots of that heat wave which
real South's to Paris then actually
there are large areas where mortality
was three hundred and four hundred
percent above long-term mean and so this
event was noticed right when it started
because it flooded the hospitals in many
areas and so the hospitals were often we
are not able to take all the emergency
incoming people into custody so some of
them here stayed on the gain we did this
was a noticeable in the time when it
happened it was also active later and
right it probably so that this was a big
societal failure in that August was the
vacation month and unexperienced young
doctor stayed in the hospital the
experience with their family usually
they took the office off nobody was
around hospitals were understaffed
difficult situation so we have learned a
lot from this heatwave and so one
interesting thing is that normally we
say heatwave there is something like a
harvesting effect and maybe you have
heard this term so it's a actually a
medical term and it quickly explained so
the argument is that the heatwave at
first round will kill the elderly people
maybe ill people that are not so
resistant to these stress factors and so
if that happens if then of course you
would expect that following such a
heatwave if there will be a deep below
the regular mortality curve because
those that haven't been killed or that
those that were killed in this period
could not be killed here and this is not
the case here so what we see actually
that disaffected people that were not
just up to die now I put it in these
words in the next weeks or so but they
had some more reasonable stretch to live
ahead of them
and actually the heatwave
affective had been noticed in
sophistical data throughout all age
categories I'll show you now so this
this is for France this was available
almost in real time in 2003 because
French is a centralized country which
has a test registry in Paris which
everything is available there and to
collect the figures for all of Europe to
took much longer and there is now an
estimated figure of an excess mortality
of 70,000 people so a huge amount you
see it here the distribution here excess
mortality of more than 200 percent
almost 300 percent in large areas and
you see how basically all European
countries were affected not only the
French with their casual August vacation
so this shows that it was a it did hit
the non prepared society but it also was
an unprecedented event and I show you
that here taking figures now from
Switzerland so these are Swiss
temperature series marked each year as a
bar and then comes 2003 a year that is
far away from the distribution and one
can actually go down and make some
estimates of the return period which is
a little dangerous but because one has
to make assumption about the statistics
but you see that everything that is
beyond 20 years according to the
Gaussian estimate has a return period of
more than thousand years so it's very
rare that you should expect that so or
actually one should not expect this
event and it is a 5.4 sigma event so it
was a tremendous event that at the time
nobody was prepared to and then the
really amazing thing was that he took
only a few years later seven years later
in 2010 was another heatwave the great
Russian heatwave and so you might recall
there were huge a forest fires in Russia
and dramatic problems with air quality
conditions in large parts of Russia and
again there was a huge estimate of s
excess mortality but on a continental
scale this actually turned out to be
even as
stronger heatwave 10 2003 I should say
now this figure here is a little an auto
scale here before here we looked at the
scale of Switzerland and here we look at
a continental scale of Europe and so on
this continental scale including this
Russian heatwave the area of this
Russian hero I should say so this is
this is 2 degrees of norm plus and 2
degrees minus so this is on the European
scale so before actually here you saw
that we had our more than 5 degrees
above normal which is on the local scale
and this classifies more as a heatwave
so the 2 degrees of course would not
really affect directly affect the
population but it occurred all as part
of this heatwave over a long period so
if you think of how to name actually the
heat the droughts and heat waves you had
in recent years maybe you should learn a
little bit from Europe because in Europe
we call this raft and this heat wave
here the great European heat waves and
only 7 year later there is one that is
even greater and so we have to call this
one now the great Russian heat range
which is a little illogical here and ok
now maybe we can recap some of that by
saying that heat waves are a major
impact factor I have highlighted only
here the human health issue there our
issue is agriculture for instance the
European heat wave 2003 it had
agricultural damage in about the value
of about 10 billion dollar meaning it's
likely the size of a hurricane
there were also big issues about
electricity fresh water resources and of
course concern how that will change with
climate change and we have also seen
that these past events they actually
have served to identify some of the
elements of these heat waves mainly his
unusual large-scale dynamics often
triggered by toshi amick circulations
and we know from several investigations
that there are lands
this atmosphere feedbacks I mean there
are some interplay between heat waves
and droughts now several of the heat
waves that you've seen they don't really
fit the statistics of the past they
appear very unusual and to discuss that
I will first now guide you quickly for
these variability hypothesis so what you
see on them so the basic idea of how
this heat wave could come about with
climate change is plotted here that
actually you have these distributions of
this would be the definition of climate
maybe I should go back so this is
temperature and the frequency and take
tails of these distributions would be
the extremes and of course if you change
the distribution then the frequency of
the extremes based on previous
definitions would could change
dramatically and disappear this been the
argument that IPCC has been making since
actually the second IPCC report now it
turns out if you try to use this model
to explain a five sigma event then it's
very difficult because the natural
variability entering of ability is about
one sigma and the warming up to now was
about 1 K which also comes about 1 Sigma
so even if you account for the mean
warming the shift it's very hard to
explain a 5 Sigma event so an but there
is another hypothesis to do that and
this is these changes in variability
that you could actually rather than
shifting the distribution you could
increase the variability and these would
lead to an increase in the frequency of
extreme warm and cold conditions if one
takes the variability alone and of
course one would take a combination of
these two factors and this hypothesis
has been started some time ago actually
1992 the very verse reading publication
and in this publication they say
variability is more important than mean
so if you really look are looking for
extremes far away from the mean then the
changes in variability are the key
factor to be concerned now to start here
this is now several years old as
introduction I show you some analysis we
did in 2003 and 2004 using a climate
change setup with a global model and the
regional model and so we are looking at
control slices basically 100 here jump
into the future and we plot our results
in a similar way as we have plotted the
observations before so this would be now
a grid point near Zurich and this would
be the control climate 1961 to 1990 and
you see that for this grid point at
least it's a little worse if first
allows the observations they fit almost
perfectly with the simulations and if
you do then the scenario integrations
you see exactly the effect which are
this issue that what we see is not only
a shift in the distribution but is a
shift in temperature by some amount plus
also an increase in variability and this
increase in variability makes extremes
up here possible which appear
unreachable in the control simulations
now this pattern of variability increase
has a it has a geographical pattern
associated with it I show it that to you
on the next slide you see here the from
the same simulations to summer mean
temperatures shift the warming of death
and you see that there is this
north-south gradient with comparatively
small warming up here and large warming
down here and here then the variability
change expressed in percent so there is
an area a fairly large area of
variability changes where this where
this increase in variability is
simulated and interestingly enough this
variability change is not co-located
with the change in mean temperature what
occurs further loss now the effect of
that on the climate you can just pick
out long grid point and it's big
depicted here namely that from a
variability pattern which resembles what
we have today there is a substantially
increased very
which would make it much more difficult
actually to do a recolor in such a
climate because there is a kind of
unexpected changes from year to year and
so together this combined also to the
warming and the increase in their
ability to increase the frequency of
very warm summers and warm heat ranges
and this issue about we have seen
already here that actually this is a
pattern which is which is very specific
to these changes for instance for the
Iberian Peninsula we would expect
dominate that this changes in verb in
occurrence of heat wave was dominated
now by the mean warming because there's
little variability change while further
north let's say in France and Germany
there would be large facts a large
impact of this change in variability and
if we do this now on the daily
statistics and look at the temperature
distribution this is what the models
suggest you see here France where this
is the control climate in blue this is
the temperature is merely histogram and
you see that now the scenario climate we
observe a shift to the warmer end but
also avoiding of the distribution
leading to an increase in heavy events
or very hot events my line the Iberian
Peninsula we find that actually this
distribution has some is not symmetric
and we see this shift but very little
change actually in variability maybe
some change in skewness so you see that
as a right and part of that T ice
becomes deeper I should say that for
this particular model simulations these
simulations that from the current
climate fit the observation surprising
well you see here in black now the
observations for the same time period
using the so-called yobs data which is a
daily 3d data set covering all of Europe
and here the
trol climate showing a good agreement
the characteristics different between
these two distributions with skewness
ended up in a barren Peninsula is
captured by the simulations I think
there is a question I maybe maybe we
should go back here to on the left-hand
side you mean well in principle you
could also have a shift and some change
of skewer skewness and some change of
variability and you would not amplify
the number of events on the right hand
side but this climate change and
informing so we should just recall it
may be the width of these distributions
our few degrees depending on strength
monthly or daily data and evolving is
also a few degrees so it's really
impossible to have a substantial shift
it's all without changing the extremes
because we shift this distribution by
substantial amounts comparable with the
variability meaning the width of the
distribution itself not you I'm
completely aunt
in the red this is a model result yeah
results is reducing the frequency that
you maintain the same frequency so the
area below these two curves is the same
so if you ride anything has to be this
way if it's a simple widening no I did
think of a more complicated answer yeah
okay now I should say before I we look a
little bit into the process so I should
show you what the scenarios recent
scenarios say in comparison also maybe
to the kind of form all of the narrative
show just just now and this you do this
first now in this analysis of simi 5ar
five models this is the most recent
climate simulations available on the
global scale and I and they have been
analyzed I actually got the data only
few weeks ago by a leaf fish or a
collaborator of mine and so what you see
here is now what is plotted here is the
change in northern hemisphere somewhat
99th percentile and so this is actually
useful quantity because it would be like
this is the warming that would affect
the hottest summer days summer has 90
days roughly 100 so the 99th percentile
is the average hottest day and so you
see that the average hot this day let's
say in Europe would warm by something
like three point five degrees this is
the scenario RCP four point five and in
North America the warming with a little
bit smaller may be free to a little more
than three degrees now this is the seam
it for four point five so this is an RCP
four point five scenario which is a
scenario that assumes that radiative
forcing associated with greenhouse gases
and their roles would not exceed four
point five watts per square meter and
maybe in other scenario is the eight
point five scenario which is you
that is forcing could go 28.5 and which
is a is a about effect of free in
anthropogenic aerosol concentrations in
the atmosphere compared to the 280 ppm
pre-industrial and you see that in this
scenario now there were these warming so
this is not a scale so the hottest
summer day would change by six or so
degrees post in North America and in
Europe now we can see whether these
models they also have this variability
increase and I show this you know here
for the scenario four point five and
here for the scenario eight point five
and I think if you look at the eight
point five baby it's easier to see the
pattern there is indeed as in a
variability increase in both North
America and Europe but in North America
is much smaller maybe only ten fifteen
twenty percent while in Europe with
cities this area is a very strong
variability increase good question so
all models available at the time of
analysis I think twenty five or
something like that so it's a large set
of models all the models help it's an
average over older models so we think
that we actually should constrain
because some of the models must
obviously be wrong because they have a
poor representation of today's natural
variability and so we did that in some
other studies I think it is a slide from
that and so if you remove these models
actually the results might change in
general actually needs a stronger
increase now another question
so this is the mean change with respect
to the variability in the control period
so 30% means that the variability
increased by 30% compared to the control
unit you can also see that in North
America we have kind of a somewhat
strange issue because here we have kind
of a much more solid signal and this is
one of the differences we find when
looking at a North American climb in the
European climate that there were North
America the models they disagree to a
larger extent than over Europe for the
summer period and I show you a few
slides to highlight actually why I think
that is the case you see for instance
that here in the week mild scenario you
have a stronger variability increase in
a large portion of Northeast US compared
to the heavy increase of so it's the
other way you would expect it the other
way around and then a lot of this has to
do with the difficulties of these models
to simulate the North American
precipitation climate and you see this
hearing just to show you the
disagreement precipitation projections
from North America for now for different
reasons and it's only it's only the near
term 20 40 to 70 vs. 1972 22,000 you can
get this from some websites maintained
by the N cup project and you see he of
the two so free American models and one
European models and you see the two of
these models they have a general
moistening more precipitation over much
of continental US or certainly they're
the flatter part of the country while
two GCMs paper check the drying by
substantial amounts maybe one or so
millimeters so there is a intrinsic
difference between these models to a
much larger extent and this is the case
in Europe and so I not sure release has
been tested but one hypothesis is that
this is the result of the sensitivity of
the North American climate with respect
to the ENSO we have already seen that
some of these heat waves then can
directly be tied to La Nina years and so
if that variability that means they're
not who represent a North American
variability you need to have to a much
better job on ENSO that you need to do
that for Europe so Europe is far away
from ENSO and we know that there is not
no strong coherent signal in the NZ
signal over Europe so this is one of the
issues that need to be looked at
carefully now I maybe skip to slide so
we have also looked over Europe this
question this mean warming versus
extreme so this is now from the old of
paper again so here you see now the mean
warming and how does the mean warming
compared against the extremes and so if
you actually look at the 99th percentile
to me to change then you see that this
maximum warming is located further north
than the mean warming meaning the heat
waves the days with very high
temperatures they they will change more
dramatically farah naaz and the
difference between these two figures is
exactly what is due to this variability
change so the variability change is has
a centered further north compared to the
mean warming and will imply that the
short-term events will also warm strong
or further mobs this pattern it's
important to understand what is
percentile mean so this is the 99th
percentile with respect to a local
temperature that means this might be bad
in some locations and Coronado's to put
it in this way
depending on where your 99th percentile
is so it's not an it's a relative fresh
hold and it will only say you something
about a change so to get around tech
tree look here now what we call it
high-impact heatwaves Varick require
that the apparent temperature is above
some threshold 41 degrees and the parent
temperature again account for heat waves
heat stress and temp and humidity stress
and you see that the there are quite
dramatic changes so the in the current
period in the control period we have a
few days where these threshold is
exceeded more couple of days and this
forty point six degree fresh toll is
actually the threshold is used in the
u.s. as a health threat and so this is
used in the warning statement of NOAA
and other agencies and so in Europe
actually we are in the current climate
kind of well treated because we have
only typically a few summer days that
are passed this limit but you see if
this comes true that every third summer
day will become like that in a large
area now we see that there is a very
complicated Tecton of these changes and
this pattern it can actually you see it
here again it can be tied to the low
altitude river basins and coastlines
so you see the major rivers Tyrone down
here the pole the Danube D April so the
major rivers river basins the low
altitude regions they have higher
temperatures and they are more likely
that to to pass this threshold of forty
point six degrees and we find that this
geographical pattern is actually
consistent with all model chains and
healthy eaters considered so it doesn't
really matter whether we use this
particular health in this index apparent
temperature one can use other indices
and one finds the same answer that it's
these low altitude river basins and
coastlines that are affected most
now I have already highlighted some
issues about the land surface coupling
and I should first maybe look at this
format from an atmospheric point of view
so what you see here are cross-sections
Oh we'll see land contrast in winter and
in winter of course we have cold
temperatures over land comparatively
warm temperatures over sea and so what
we have here is a density stratification
meaning that Inventor the atmosphere
runs over the continent and doesn't take
notice
significantly notice in general at least
of what is happening below because it's
shielded by by strong by surface
inversions and strong stability while in
summer and this means that some SST
variability must play an important role
in affecting the internal variations
while in some of the situation is kind
of opposite well we will have warm
temperatures a cold compare the cold
temperatures over sea and warm
temperatures over land and we actually
couple the land surface to the deep
atmosphere by convection so there is
convection over land with the diurnal
cycle and that means that another
element comes into play and this is the
soil moisture variability which plays an
important role in governing kind of
coupling the atmosphere to the surface
and of course that brings a lot of
additional elements in our system which
are complicated we need to count for
soil moisture content the terrorists or
more propellants we need to think of how
the energy the available energy at the
surface is made available into sensible
and latent heat flux so the decisive
question is how is the net radiation
which is the sum of short life and long
wave radiation how it's that spent into
sensible and latent heat fluxes and you
see that in a global mean actually
eighty percent of that energy goes into
the latent heat and only 20 percent one
or actually one six goes into the
sensible heat
and doing that well would also mean that
one has to have an idea of how soil
moisture developed a function of time
however poor transpiration runoff and so
on effects dead and there so we think
that this actually explains some of
these variability issues and so the
variability issue is explained by the
fact that we have here another threshold
effect which is the venting point so
what you see here is a soil moisture
evolution from spring to fall and so
typically the amplitude of death on land
mass is about 150 millimetres which
corresponds to maybe a couple of around
forty watts over period of three months
so it's a huge number that is available
and this huge number is actually
available for cooling so we miss is the
cooling rate that the evaporation can
act on soil temperature now if we get if
you are close to the wilting point and
so we extract a little bit more moisture
from the soil means that we will run
into this threshold effect meaning we
cannot lower the soil moisture
contribution for any deeper so and I
show you first for the European wheat
wave that it this is really a signal or
feature that is relevance so what you
see here are now simulations for for
heat waves from seventy six ninety four
2003 and 2005 and you see maybe it's
quicker to see down here the number of
nights number of hot days where the T
max is larger than the 90s percentile
and you see that
so the first heat wave in seventy six is
referred to as the UK heat wave or the
England heat wave actually then this
heat wave stretched parts of the
Mediterranean coast and the Alpine
region this is the 2003 heat wave which
is affected Spain France Switzerland
parts of Austria Germany and Italy and
this was a 2005 heat wave which was kind
of small about fairly similar in the
location and the top diagram shows you
now the observations at the stations
locations and you see that these
simulations which are driven by lateral
by true data as a lateral boundary so we
uses regional model and try these models
by two data as the lateral boundary and
you see that in general these
simulations capture what is going on
like here
UK parts of France and here the extent
of the heatwave 2005-2008 free now if we
do these experiments now so we redo
these experiments but we don't allow the
soil moisture to dry out but we actually
prescribed a soil moisture at
climatological levels and this is a very
similar to experiments where you
prescribe the sea surface temperature in
its effect but you do with easterland
and if one does that then so this is the
simulations with the dynamic land
surface coupling and this is without
land surface coupling and you see that
most of the heat waves they lose not
completely but they lose a lot of their
strengths so we have still that this
would still be a heat wave but compared
to the observed heat wave in 2003 which
this large area affected area it would
be much smaller actually Switzerland
would not be affected by seriously
affected by this kind of heat wave and
this is the case for all three heat
waves means that the soil moisture kind
of spring soil moisture it plays a key
role for these heat waves and there I
should say yeah there is one study which
shows that we showed that using only
observational data pens I chick from the
group of ron smith comparing a case in
august 2000 against this heat wave
august 2003 and looking here at active
vegetation and soil my soil temperature
below and what you see is here that in
the forests in this area here there we
are able to remain active while
not of the fields in agricultural area
kind of vegetation shut down ever pour
transpiration and as a result the NDVI
these active vegetation index decreased
quite dramatically now you see The
Associated impact on temperature that
actually in these areas here soil
temperatures measure measured from from
the astro satellite actually rose by 20
degrees in comparison to the August
three years ago by low what the forests
where this forest still remained active
and evaporated water the difference was
almost 10 degrees smaller now if we look
into these soil moisture issues it's not
only we need to recognize that it's a
complicated chain of things that happens
and it's not only saw watch it's also
convection because this I've shown you
this diagram before and of course the
soil moisture evolution will strongly be
affected by the soil water balance so
just think of this would represent a
patch of soil accumulating everything
over the depths and the so the rate of
change of soil moisture stored in this
in this piece of volume would be
determined precipitation
evapotranspiration and runoff and all
three of these are not easy quantities
so it's not so evident how runoff will
change went almost to change and
certainly not evident with precipitation
and evapotranspiration and so I come to
believe that this precipitation responds
to changes in soil moisture is one of
the keys behind understanding the
climate change in the mid-latitudes so
we have here let's assume that we would
like to know how precipitation change
with soil moisture and this and I'll
show you in the next slide why this is
so important so actually assume that the
soil gets drier and if the soil gets
drier and precipitation bhoot increase
then of course it would would actually
break soil moisture tourists try to
restore soil moisture to more normal
levels in putting it here so in this
case we would refer to a positive
feedback there are actually more
precipitation falls over the wet soils
you refer to the positive feedbacks
while the negative feedback would be the
other way around where more positive
precipitation would follow what right
fine
and so the you find a disagreement in
the published literature which two of
these effects dominates and so the
positive feedback it would actually it's
decisive where this feedback is positive
or negative because the positive
feedback would amplify the hydrological
response to climate change so if an area
gets drier then it would mean
precipitation will reduced as a result
of the drying and it would become even
drier so it's a positive feedback while
a negative feedback would moderate the
hydrological response to climate change
because if an area would get dry or
precipitation would increase as a result
of destroying in soil moisture and this
would moderate it and so you think that
of course one favours the kind of the
left hand picture because one would
argue that more precipitation and more
soil moisture more water in the soil
would also allow more precipitation but
in fact there are number of studies and
the opinion on this is is not the same
so there are a lot of uncertainties due
to the complex change of processes that
are involved and one of the complexities
that is involved here is that this a lot
of this precipitation which we are
interested in is in the form of
convective precipitation with a strong
diurnal cycle I'll show you a nice
example here so it is shows a diurnal
convection over Europe is a three-day
stretch and it shows you how on each
days this
now it shows on each day how the
convection starts you see so now it's
the first day second day third day so we
have a diurnal cycle in the convection
on precipitation signal meaning that we
are looking at the pulsating phenomena
which extends our large areas all of
Europe and also substantial parts of
North America it's fairly similar so
what we and then we have to recall that
precipitation is convective
precipitation which is parameterized by
rise all of T C with some sensitivities
which we maybe have a problem so what we
try to do is to investigate whether this
soil moisture precipitation feedback was
a was the same model the same way in low
resolution models maybe we would use a
convection scheme here the kontiki
convection scheme or in high resolution
model where we would explicitly simulate
the convection and so we're doing this
type of simulations and we are using
just simply wet and try soy alloys your
initial conditions to see whether
precipitation in such simulations
increases or decreases so a positive
feedback would mean that the wet
simulations the wet initial conditions
would have more precipitation than the
control and substantially more than the
dry initial conditions and I show you
maybe first just a few looks at how
these simulations compare so I show you
here now a precipitation field that were
covering the alpine region and you see
on the right-hand side the low
resolution results at 25 kilometers for
the same month and on the left-hand side
you see now the convective precipitation
which shows them maybe not realistic but
more realistic signature and what you
see on the left-hand side so you see the
diurnal convection in some of this wing
now we have a phase of diurnal
convection
and then another synoptic system is
moving in right now
now we don't argue with these
simulations that the details of this
convective that the distribution of
these convective cells is realistic so
we think there must be else what we
think are we hope that actually we can
do look at this feedback in a public
fashion I'll show you maybe another look
at some of the clouds how these clouds
look now a perspective view in a small
area of these model simulations and you
see those clouds that are resolved
explicitly when you see that in the
seven kilometer models which we use it
is a comparison here the majority of
clouds cannot be represented and if you
display also the parameterize clouds
then most models get kind of a slight
drama because they see how bad their
clouds look these are convective clouds
in a parameterize models maybe it's use
such models maybe it's worse while
looking at how these clouds look and we
know that that this explicit this
representation of these clouds has some
big big advantages in particular we can
have a much better representation of the
diurnal cycle so on the in black you see
now the diurnal cycle from 0 to 24 UTC
and you see this afternoon
convective peak which is in the evening
hour while the parameterize convection
has this signal much too early typically
around noon so and this is a
characteristic problem well known for
actually all parameterization schemes
are aware of and so this bias can be
corrected with a explicit convection we
can actually use that also to start the
other factors but really skip that here
so here we now look at the results for
this month-long integration though this
was one month which at the lateral
boundaries was driven by the observed
conditions of the atmosphere and we
simulate each of these panels as
three simulations one where we have a
dry initial soil and one very of a vet
initial soil and this the drying rate is
kind of at the outposts of natural
variability and black is the control and
you see that this already now that you
see here now is pulsating convection
which happens every day so this is a
mean area average precipitation amounts
now if you summarize all of that the
mean as the mean diurnal cycle you get a
surprising result namely that the mean
diurnal cycle of precipitation in the
parrot rice dandy the explicit model has
a different sign it's not only a
different amplitude but a different sign
so what we see here for the dry soil and
for the low-resolution model is
parameterized convection that we have a
positive feedback because the moist soil
produces more precipitation the dry soil
less precipitation while in the two kilo
meter simulations we have the dry soil
produces more precipitation and the
moist soil produces less precipitation
and so a very puzzling result and what
can understand it actually or that it's
consistent with the literature which has
proposed that such a negative feedback
is possible because you can have deeper
thermals because you have more energy in
and you can have deeper thermals and
trigger convection in circumstances
where you would not be able over a moist
soil and so for this months at this
region it doesn't need to be the same we
have a different opinion of these two
models about the feedback and situation
is even worse actually if we now look at
the same now for a whole set of models
this one being the explicit
parameterization and then form for
simulations with different convection
schemes then you see that each
convection scheme has its own mood as to
say like the teach K is positive the
teach cape closure Isis is also positive
but slightly smaller kind fridge is a
kind of almost neutral the kind Ridge
berthold again is positive
and you all even find some I know
actually this is negative the contract
is negative and so there are big
differences between those different
schemes and we have done these
experiments are part of these
experiments twice so below here we use
the same model now the same dynamical
core but with another model version
meaning a lot of changes have been made
the typical thing you have to upgrade to
a model and so this changes between
dudes to model releases this may be five
years in verb so it's quite substantial
difference so and we repeat it some of
these experiments down here and you see
that qualitatively the the character of
each Convention scheme is maintained so
the character of a convection scheme is
very strong and maintained over chain
other model changes so we can say that
this uncertainty is evident across a
wide range of convection
parametrizations and what we are trying
to do is really to get rid of this
uncertainty by doing by trying to
simulate some of these climate
simulations with cloud resolve as cloud
resolving resolutions now I should say
we - as a form of look out as one would
like to use these client cloud resolving
models for climate studies I should also
point out another advantage namely the
question do climate models converge and
if this issue is always has always been
an important item in regular or normal
modeling studies there one would request
that if we refine the numerical
resolution that solution should converge
and it's very hard to do this convergent
experiments with parameterize convection
because you actually we know that we
would it would violate the implicit
assumptions but weak you can do these
convergence tests now in for the cloud
resolving models and I show you here
results from a very recent paper where
we zoom in now into one area here and
the colors you see here are the clouds
vertically integrated cloud moisture
content and you see that these cloud
they depend did they strongly depend
actually on the resolution is what you
would expect it actually did the 4.4
kilo meter clouds are much larger and
smooth than the 500 meter kilometer
cloud so certainly the simulations don't
converge in structure so the structure
that we obtain they are very different
but if we actually compute the bulk
convergence property meaning the way how
these clouds and T's clouds eat the
atmosphere for instance or moisten the
atmosphere we find that they essentially
deliver the same type of thing so there
is this astounding degree of convergence
despite that is it large sensitivity
with respect to structure okay I think
that was my last slide is content yeah
so here is a summary so we have seen
that heat waves have very significant
societal impacts already today and it's
quite likely that they will become even
more relevant with climate change and
temperatures that appear extremely hot
or unthinkable and unusual today they
might become quite common in the future
if you think that eight degrees warmer
or six degrees warmer this is in the
scale of climate change and very hot
summer temperatures could result there
is some evidence from the models and
observations and understanding they need
some regions climate warming will also
be accompanied by increases in
variability and so that changes in heat
wave is not only the warming signal
alone but we need to account for changes
in the whole statistical distribution
and from that we think according to
current models that Europe will be
strongly affected we've also seen and
regional projects and still have larger
I would even say large uncertainties it
depends also to some extent on the
region and it's key issues that here
require further assessment our land
surface processes and moist convection
but we have also seen it in for some
areas this inability to have model
agreement stems from the oceanic part of
the
actually no good question so most of the
simulations you've seen from some of the
scenic 5 simulations I think there are
simulations that do that but for the
auto simulations for the regional
simulations there is no relationship and
theory this is an issue that is of
concern and should be looked into as
well I agree so you the point that is
being made is that changes in co2
concentration might change
but you focused on this as sort of
small-scale interactions between not
knowing anything I would have actually
guessed that one of the other controls
good point
so I've I think what we see from these
models actually is that in the like if
you do the air each over all models then
you see that some variability is not
changed dramatically but there are some
reductions in winter variability and
these reductions in winter variability
are interpreted by the fact that the
north-south temperature grading these
kind of will be simulated to become
smaller and so and there is more
moisture in the atmosphere so actually
smaller or Vico cyclones in the average
a smaller number of cyclones is able to
maintain the north-south temperature
gradient but so to make it to ask you a
question on the other direction is that
we don't think that the models are good
enough to make projections of these
variability the synoptic scale changes
because they have a huge problem finding
predicting blocking blocking frequencies
which of course are relevant for for
heat waves they extended into a cell
for comparison to just to have her for
1961 $2.99
well that's just the tradition because
our simulations are many of these
simulations they end in 2100 can hate to
agree on the protocol and in this
protocol the normal stop of simulation
is 2100 for a large set of simulations
some of them are continued so what is
certainly done also so there are our
studies I showed some diagrams as well
for intermediate periods like 2040 to
2070 and the next IPCC report will
actually have a chapter chapter 11 or
near-term climate change which will only
look up to 2050 but for some of these
studies it's quite clear that of course
the signal-to-noise ratio is smaller if
you look at the next 30 or 40 years
actually the part of natural variability
which we cannot predict will grow in
proportion so it will be hard to show a
clear signal for the next 20 or so years
the regional mob had to take time so do
you suspect it those simulations were
done with I could be the case so also
it's clear that these models I mean
those that are using these models they
should know that these are huge
apparatus and so basically you have to
rely on a community to generate a model
that to some extent you need to do that
and so it's also clear that all of these
models in some way are tuned implicitly
or explicitly so that the model produces
nice results we Amin quantities is a
tunable issue to some extent but I think
to protune a heatwave actually is much
more difficult to do that so we will see
how the what the results say may be also
demands that we started for this soil
moisture precipitation feedback was one
specific month that maybe had an odd
behavior compared to the average we
don't know
and the fact that the bully couple is
set free to do whatever 100 is how much
faith you have on the variability
instrument at the end of that that the
interval simulations when all you have
compared to
I I think there is some limitations in
my face in this variability issues we we
have done a lot of analysis and we on
this representation of a relative at a
paper just recently in GRL they are we
look into that again with another
ensemble of models that so-called
ensembles models and there we see that
these models have generally a tendency
to overestimate the variability from
these processes which would actually be
in line with effect that there's almost
a precipitation feedback could be less
positive then the models assume so that
would actually reduce the variability so
most of the models actually
overestimated our ability threshold some
of your drying things out where you
didn't that's right yeah so the idea so
we I didn't talk about that in more
detail but it's all moisture threshold
it will not really be important in a
very Mediterranean climate where you
actually cross that threshold anyway
every year so it will not be a
fundamental change to the climate with
climate change but in the intermediate
zone where you in the current climate EE
rarely exceed this threshold but in the
future we will do so maybe every second
year it will add to the variability they
gives you the
is part of the boundary condition yeah
so we're entering a paper we don't have
a now so it's true so for most of the
simulations like the thick so if you do
the current climate simulation then now
I need to be careful on the on which
mortal soul on the cheesy ends which are
also used to drive the scenarios from
the regional models of course they have
a ice module and they are coupled
atmosphere ocean she seems so they are
northern hemisphere ice extent may may
be aught with from observation so I
validation around for that parameter but
I don't know how it looks like but there
is a dynamical ice sheet in these models
I mean the the sea ice yeah the sea ice
is dynamically treated in the coupled
models and may be overestimated or
underestimated so compared to current
observations most model actually they
underestimate the retreat of the Arctic
sea ice
most of the model have a much slower
retreat and has been observed at least
in the last 20 years